though their reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey ring
I'm gringo wall don't know if you guys
have caught on we have watched JK
Rowling and David Yates's fantastic
piece in the crimes of Grendel boo
before we go into this review we got to
say a thank you to the wonderful people
over at RealD 3d for having us at their
nightclub party yes there's a lot of
people there and it was like la popping
music it's a great time with a lot of
wonderful food but more importantly the
3d in this movie and I'm we're not just
saying it otherwise we just say thank
you there's actually a really good 3d
there showed us it is something
different with their glasses this time
around yeah they've got the best most
state-of-the-art screen and whatnot with
the truest colors and the brightest
tones and and honestly this is show
that's 3d yeah it does it really does
show throughout really I mean it's not
cast a comment like when the logo was
like that's the best it's gonna get and
actually yeah so thank you guys for
doing that but we're gonna talk about
the movie now is our gonna be our
non-spoiler review I don't think we're
gonna do a spoiler review for this movie
to be honest but yeah let's just go
right into this putting this out there
right now Johnny Depp is Grindelwald was
probably like especially looking back on
this film is probably the best part
about this movie it's called the crimes
of Grindelwald you want to see what
giant ups gonna do for this woman my
personal opinion Newt Scamander is still
my favorite character but Johnny Depp is
Grindelwald did a setup of Grindelwald
and the finale with Grindelwald were the
best moments in this film the opening of
this movie is like it is an awesome
awesome opening and the introduction of
or the reintroduction that Grindelwald
is so good i rewatched the first
fantastic beast a couple days ago there
was that part of me was like it's gonna
do in the sequel cuz you're like is he
gonna do like another chewing up the
scenery kind of performance but you know
he's very subtle and smooth yeah I liked
his interpretation and the some of the
best scenes and the probably the best
scenes in this movie feature him in it
he's almost in
element I guess rightfully so because
yeah it's a character and the other a
highly-anticipated thing in this movie
Jude Law's Dumbledore incredibly
charming I really enjoyed his it is
young if you were to hear Jude Law's
playing young Dumbledore it's exactly
how you'd expect it you know what that's
not a bad thing it's some really good
stuff and it was cool that the most
intriguing new elements and the best new
elements to this film came in the form
of the two most hyped up elements were
June Law and Johnny Depp so those
elements were awesome good opening great
finale it's still Eddie Redmayne as Newt
Scamander is still my favorite character
I really like him the first fantastic
piece a hell of a lot I quite enjoy him
again here he's got a little heart and
soul and he's got that quirky kind of
every managed quality that you love yes
oh it's so so true
it's called fantastic beasts so you know
you got some of those returning beasts
from the first one and you introduced
some new beasts as well in this movie
where he's from x-men beasts from x-men
is in this film Wow
this cinematic crossovers might be a
little too much nowadays but it works in
this film people Nicholas Hoult the
beast in this film there's some new ones
that are introduced that you see T's and
the trailers like the one that he's
riding through the water amazing visuals
there and also like the giant cat lion
hybrid that you see in the trailer China
yeah that was that was some awesome
awesome designs for the Potterheads they
noticed that Nagini Voldemort's snake is
actually an asian woman that's brought
into this film and they have a
transformation scene that just looked
absolutely incredible it was incorrect
it happened it was like whoa yeah Retta
ball they actually make slightly more of
a moment out of that than even in the
trailers so when the moment itself shows
up you're like oh yeah you know I
haven't really reached any of the Harry
Potter films I've seen them all I might
say that this is in the terms of like
costume design production design this is
one of the best looking they've done the
costumes in here are fantastic stuff
yeah hahaha
fantastic
I don't get it oh sorry you know cuz the
the film ah the Amazing Spider amazing
yeah in this movie seriously everything
is beautiful to behold I mean yeah the
designs the world the effects the
creatures the costumes the way it's shot
and captured the music like it's such a
well-constructed beautiful movie yeah
the cinematography is excellent in it
and the music by James Newton Howard on
those technical scales just amazing
amazing elements for sure they really do
maintain the aesthetic vibe so like no
matter what's happening
you're just thrilled to be in the
Wizarding World mhm and all that that
implies and it's cool because you also
get to see like the French Ministry of
Magic a lot of this takes place in Paris
and you get to see in America in
different parts of the world and not
just Hogwarts you know yeah okay so we
pass the watch time mark the past a
four-minute mark where they usually
click off in the idea okay all that
being said and I mean it this movie is
also boring as [ __ ] I mean everything I
said right there that is all very much
true the biggest things with it with a
lot of these movies it comes down to the
writing and directing and that's where
the weakness of this film comes into
play and hence you end up walking out
with a very messy poorly constructed
films is the terrible joke I have is
fantastic beasts in the overstuffed
subplot from beginning to end it just
seemed like they were starting a new
movie every next scene not that totally
shifted something like totally jarring
its plot jarring because the first
half-hour to 40 minutes gosh every new
scene is a new plot yeah not like the
plot is thickening and the plot is
enhancing it's a new play yeah it's like
a katamari that keeps on picking a plot
lines and elements and details and it
doesn't ever give any of them enough
time to breathe or to have an emotional
impact really like it's a really plot II
movie that has these scenes that are
really short just rocketing through
other things and yeah it's hard to put
your teeth in any because I wouldn't say
and it's
lazy writing because of the fact that
it's it's not lacking in imagination
that's the furthest thing from the
problem with this film it's and it's
full of imagination and it's even trying
to get at some relevant subtext like
Harry Potter books do the thing is it's
wildly overstuffed you could just tell
there's so many people afraid to tell JK
Rowling you know this isn't a book you
gotta cut this back necessary for the
movie what do you say maybe a truncate a
couple of moments and maybe yes Allah
date a few characters like you would
when adapting a book I was like kind of
editing it in my head when I was
watching the movie if you just focused
on the main things the trailer
advertised okay they're looking for
credence good guys are looking for treat
it's Grindelwald looking for treatments
and then into the journey and turns it
to the window all the crimes of
Grindelwald instead it's if you look at
the first fantastic piece you got four
new main characters in their new Tina
Queenie
Jacob Kowalski I say Mike and then you
got the introduction of you know
essentially Grindelwald and then you
also have the main beast or in the first
one which is Creedence and in this movie
they bring all them back as main focal
points but then they also introduce like
forty six new characters like this movie
wants to make everybody the main care
it's not an ensemble succesfully in
light of and this isn't comparison to
Harry Potter and B and like be more like
the Harry Potter movies it's just an
example of where this movie is flawed if
you look at the Harry Potter films like
I've only read the first three books I
may have read all of them but let's just
look at the films most of the movie is
following Harry you rarely cut away from
Harry to focus on other characters
so while Newt is technically the lead of
even this movie a lot of this movie was
me going oh yeah this person's in it oh
yeah this story Lajo
yeah like it was constant I would
sometimes forget newts in this movie
because you would go mute story light
then this story line in this story line
then this story like the nude story
story lines in this story like it's not
lazy writing it's just really poorly
constructed poorly structured especially
when it wants to drive emotional points
home because the other thing too is this
is an oddly titled movie because we
don't really ever witness any of the
crimes of Grindelwald no he doesn't
really commit very many crime and in the
movie the beasts don't really have
anything to do because it the first
movie most of that movie is about
fantastic beasts were they are they okay
do you know yeah and this movie takes
that is such a weird jumping-off point
to where it's almost like the first
movie doesn't exactly matter that much
other than being an introduction to the
world and all these characters and the
fact that Grindelwald is a threat yes
and in this movie you know I admire that
they're going for you know Grindelwald
'he's whole point of view is that he
just views muggles as a different class
of creature and he wants to you know
take over impurity and it's it's a very
much like a neo-nazi kind of you know
allegory of sorts but it just doesn't
hit oh none of the main stuff hits home
there was one subplot in here that when
it occurred I'm not in the camp that was
ever confused I never I didn't read the
books enough to latch on to a lot of
things that are I'm sure really strong
nuggets and elements that are for the
Potter fans there's one very specific
element that I and I know would be a
spoiler if I talked about it he's
suddenly going to this giant backstory
on it dealing with zoe kravitz his
character towards the end of the movie
when it happens and I was as they're
going I don't care we don't need this
like I wasn't confused when it occurred
but in terms of a movie it was like I
just don't care and I know this movie
currently as we're filming this has a
57% Iran tomatoes I understand that
majority of critics are recommending
this movie I know there's a lot of
potter fans who really do adore this
film and at the screening we were at
most of the people we were with we all
felt the same way it was it was kind of
a sluggish experience when you got so
many things going up in your mind
to keep up with so much and nothing is
really emotionally gripping or
captivating you wind up with a film that
feels tedious
yeah and it's weird to have something
move so fast and be so kind of glacial
at the same time yes there's no bad
performances in here no one does a bad
job in terms of their performance
but I will say there's a lot of boring
characters it's the main difference it's
like I know
Ezra Miller is really a fantastic actor
yeah where to find it yes I love the
word fantastic I know he's a great actor
but Creedence is so boring in such a
focal point in this movie to do it's
just everyone's like we got to find him
and then when you see him he'll like
look at ya and that's it the movie with
or sub sub plus there's a lot of plot
lines that just get dropped things that
are introduced and twists that occur
where you're like that never comes back
this is weird this should have been like
two movies or like a three hour movie or
planning on making five movies you could
like eat some stuff and left it for your
next one they all gonna be like this
because maybe you should make eight
movies or something cuz I don't feel the
first ones over stuff I like the first
one the first one is fun and maybe a
little bit light for what it is but it
does all the Harry Potter things to it
again relatively well this one is just
missing that crucial element where
you're allowed to be intimate with any
of the characters because it's just a
plot movies yes so hard it's just like
here's a plot point and here's yeah
and here's a plot point and here's a
plot point and there's never really any
like the few scenes that work are the
ones that last long enough for you to
kind of pay attention to somebody and
drink in their mannerisms and what they
might be feeling literally it's the
opening and finale or the best parts of
this movie I was like even if it's messy
it's gonna be fun but it wasn't fun no
the magic was very choked with a movie
filled with a lot of great visual
looking stuff and a lot of technical
like magic because you're in the
Wizarding World
the movie doesn't feel magical that's
the most disheartening part
and I really feel like you have the
writing section which is insanely
overstuffed and trying to include way
too much if you pay attention to the
Harry Potter books they get longer yes
there you go
so you'd expect JK Rowling to go well
this is my sequel I'm gonna do more and
she does everyone's too afraid to tell
her now David Yates it was so weird the
best I can do in comparing what he did
with his direction here is like when you
get a director to do a great episode of
TV but they're really just fulfilling
what's required for the episode it's
like they know where to point the camera
they know how this technically has to be
done simultaneously you can feel a
strong lack of passion it's kind of like
watching Ridley Scott do alien covenant
where yeah he knows what to do he knows
where the camera belongs he knows that
what needs to be edited but there's a
lack of excitement and passion and what
they're doing these rection doesn't have
an end there's about ten Harry Potter
based films now and out of those ten he
has directed 26 does he love it this
much or did he like sell his solar so
he's announced to direct the next few as
well and I'm like I don't think when
this guy decided to become a director
he's born in the 60s and the Barry
Potter books didn't come out till the
90s I can't imagine that he was like can
all the things I wanted to ever direct
I'm only doing every Potter from here on
out when we won that Oscar for the girl
in the cafe this is really what I had in
my life he's right Tarzan didn't pan out
okay only Harry Potter world stuff I
really feel like he's over this it feels
like he knows what to do but he's not
passionate about this job anymore I
can't blame him because what was he
really done this is a 6-1 and this is
like almost 10 years of his life I can't
imagine that he's feeling as strong as
he did when he closed out the original
franchise you know yeah well and I mean
hey no no disrespect to David Yates I
think he's done a great job with you
know all the installments of this this
was is really the only Potter world
movie I don't like Wow yeah
I like them all except for this one and
it's the one movie where it's like I
didn't love the first fantastic beast
but being in the world was enough to
make me you know appreciate that
variance in this movie loses that
element even for me and I feel like one
of the charms of the original Harry
Potter series for me was the way that
they change directors frequently and yes
not kind of different kind of a Mission
Impossible thing yeah yeah exactly and
and I know that it's a tall order to
bring anybody else and after someone has
directed Harry Potter for so long but at
the same time I'm like no one else
there's nobody else yeah maybe my step
and I also realized that yeah there is a
scripting issue because you know I'm
sure even though David Yates probably
has a very tight working relationship
with JK Rowling now it's still probably
hard to be like hey can you change this
lucrative franchise that all came out of
your head as much as I can [ __ ] at
people for not being brave enough to
criticize her yes script I'm like a
would I be brave enough to like I know
enough listen ma'am I think that yeah I
mean the last thing is like that one of
the main hashtags to this movie has in
the marketing has been protect the
secrets and there's a couple of big plot
to us that occur in this movie there's
one that's supposed to cause a freakout
moment that I think some people are
freaking out about if you like this
movie you'll freak if you're in the 57
percent or whatever [ __ ] wood Potter
fans at the screening and non Potter
fans
I found the Potter fans were kind of
annoyed and confused by the twist the
other hope group was like I just don't
care and it's again in a movie that
handled itself better i I fully admit
that I might say something completely
different but as this movie stands all
the attempts at twists and surprises I
was sort of like I don't really feel any
impact of this and I am a little bit
like well the books touch on something
in the area and none of it involves this
so I really do think that it's a it's a
wildly overstuffed screenplay the
directing lacks and passion
and everything in between everyone
else's job they either everyone does a
great job with those two ingredients
take up a majority of how you end up
leaving a film yeah unfortunately I
found myself really bored through most
of this the best word I could use is I
was kind of sluggish to sit through this
team as a one-dimensional pace it moves
at one clip the whole time and almost
never stops to slow down or yeah yeah I
mean this is the first time in a long
time I've seen a movie where I
appreciate almost everything about it
except the actual delivery of that story
at the court I'll close this out with a
page from the day shadow I'm a positive
note yes I want to say a page today
shout to Victoria Huntley who lives all
the way in the UK and I want to show you
how specifically because we were last
talking to messages you mentioned that
you went to a Halloween party I remember
you said you did a lot of drugs and you
got insanely drunk you know had it's a
wild kind of or you know it doesn't
matter bottom line you were dressed up
as Hermione I'm really happy that you
got a rock and awesome Halloween costume
and that the Wizarding World still
continues on because at the end of the
day even though I don't like this movie
I'm happy that there are fans out there
like you who still get to experience and
dwell in the Wizarding World so this
movie can still keep you happy that it's
still ongoing positivity thanks Victoria
your magical to us alright guys well did
you see the crimes a Grindelwald do you
want to watch more about maybe you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification belt check us on
patreon we got TV show reaction watch
along as weekly QAS and music video
coverage we'd love to have you become a
patronage it's a day